okay so the topic of this video is
overpopulation and kind of some of the
consequences by the way the picture
you're seeing is obviously a map of the
world with the darker red being the
areas of the world where people are most
concentrated so if you want to pause
this and kind of just explore go right
ahead
but we're gonna go ahead and get started
so when it comes to overpopulation well
we have to face the reality that there
are currently over seven point six
billion people and there are
consequences with numbers of people that
large when we look at this graph right
here we can see that for much of human
history the population of humans has
been pretty small but with in the past I
don't know maybe four or five hundred
years or so the population has grown
exponentially well you know what are
some of the side effects of over seven
point six billion people well with more
people means that there's a greater need
for resources and when we look at this
graph right here this pie graph of the
United States and how energy is used you
can see that only a very small
percentage about seven percent of energy
in the United States is renewable and by
that means it can be replenished and
that it really can't run out you can't
really run out of solar power wind power
and hydroelectric power unfortunately
the numbers only seven percent in the
United States most energy here in the US
is what falls into the category of
non-renewable and these are resources
that are used faster than they are
naturally created the big three being
coal oil or petroleum and natural gas
and so through the use of coal oil
natural gas fossil fuels that's where
the most electricity and power is
generated here in the US well if we
examine this graph that shows which
nations overpopulated you have the red
bars which are increasing pretty rapidly
and that shows less develop
countries such as maybe India and China
any of the blue bars which are also
going up but at a much slower rate and
that would imply countries like the US
and those of Europe well when you look
at this it's a little misleading which
countries are overpopulated well both
but for different reasons when you look
at the red bars the countries of the red
bars yeah they're producing the most
number of people but when you look at
the countries of the blue bars like the
US and Europe you know we these
countries here are the biggest users of
Earth's natural resources so we're kind
of both overpopulated but for different
reasons so now let's talk about some of
the consequences of this okay so one of
the consequences of kind of using the
Earth's natural resources as we are is
what is called climate change or global
warming well there's a problem
first of all Earth has a greenhouse
effect and the greenhouse effect is
really misunderstood because the
greenhouse effect is crucial to the
survival of life on Earth but the
greenhouse effect is out of balance in
this picture here is there literally a
greenhouse that surrounds planet Earth
of course not but Earth has an
atmosphere that kind of acts like a
greenhouse well what do we mean by that
what do we mean that the atmosphere acts
like a greenhouse well in Earth's
atmosphere is some carbon dioxide some
water vapor some methane ch4 is methane
and as rays of energy from the Sun
strike earth these gases do a wonderful
job of kind of trapping Earth's trapping
heat and energy from the Sun to warm the
planet and this is what we call the
greenhouse effect and I say yay the
greenhouse effect because it really
keeps earth warm and livable well what
is this thing called global warming or
climate change well the main cause comes
from excess carbon dioxide from the
burning of fossil fuels you know the
picture here shows a lot of cars
burning gasoline for energy in order to
fuel them's not to feel themselves and
in this picture we see you know
factories given off air pollution and
burning fossil fuels as well well we
also see that the removal of forests
around the world we'll talk more about
deforestation later but we know that
plants and trees can remove carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere because they
need carbon dioxide to do photosynthesis
so removal of forests is a big cause of
global warming as well because we're
removing the things that will take
carbon dioxide out of the sky and out of
the atmosphere
so let's come back to this diagram here
over the past you know few decades and
centuries really we've been seeing a
rise of ch4 methane a rise of water
vapor a rise of carbon dioxide that's
mainly from the burning of fossil fuels
as a result these gases hurt our are
trapping extra amounts of heat from the
Sun and this is what we kind of call
global warming or climate change and
this is what we're of course gonna have
to face as a society so the fear is that
over time climate patterns can change
ice caps polar ice caps now in North and
South Pole can melt here we see a
picture on the left from 1984 and on the
right from 2012 and you can see quite a
difference in the polar ice of these two
pictures well this water this ice that
melted has to go somewhere and it goes
into the oceans and so what we see is
you know flooding around the world you
know cities like Venice Italy are
experiencing massive flooding as a
result of higher sea levels we're seeing
around the world with extra you know
with the a warmer earth we're seeing
stronger storms around the world because
again with the greater temperatures
comes more evaporation of water into the
atmosphere and so we're seeing more
intense storms around the war
we're also seeing in certain areas
drought as the temperature warms again
this is going to change climate patterns
around the world and we're seeing areas
or other around the world that aren't
used to see an extreme drought becoming
very dry and so what are ways in which
oh you know we can help on number-one
but the obvious is let's try to reduce
the use of fossil fuels encouraging
alternative energies such as wind power
and solar energy wherever possible also
trying to be a little more fuel
efficient if you have the means to
explore fuel-efficient automobiles well
wonderful if not there are ways in which
you can help is well carpool ride bikes
use public transportation these are ways
to cut down on our use of fossil fuels
also you know planting trees we
mentioned that the removal of forests is
a big concern so growing trees which
then remove carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere is a great way to help
okay so changing topic let's talk about
something called acid rain if you
remember the pH scale from earlier in
the school year on the pH scale items
below a seven have more hydrogen ions
and hydrogen's closer to 14 have fewer
hydrogen ions and directly in the middle
of seven and the pH scale is what we
would call neutral well so acid rain
what is acid rain it's precipitation
generally rainfall with a lower than
normal pH well first of all what is the
normal pH and if you notice normal pH is
around five point six on normal pH is
actually a bit acidic so therefore acid
rain is even lower when we talk about
acid rain we're talking generally about
rain in the lower force on the pH scale
and so well what causes that's what
causes acid rain in the picture we see a
factory given off a lot of so2 s and n
Oh X's and the stands for sulfur dioxide
and nitrogen oxides these are two
pollutants that are released into the
atmosphere from the burning of fossil
fuels and factories are not the only
machines I guess at fault of this you
know automobiles do this as well
well when the so2 and NO x is when the
sulfur dioxide and nitrogen oxides are
in the sky they react with rainwater
they were react the rainwater to form
sulfuric acid and nitric acid and of
course with the rain these acids then
fall to the ground and then they soak
into the soil they flow into rivers and
lakes and streams and oceans and ponds
and some of the effects as it turns
waterways more acidic ecosystems more
acidic whether it's land-based or
aquatic based and aquatic even more so
is harmed because again rivers and lakes
they all kind of feed into one area here
and with that the acids kind of
accumulate in a queue
and therefore the the wildlife in that
area tends to perish at a greater rate
than those on land but you know plant
life as well as greatly impact did you
see these trees here in this forest are
completely dead because of their roots
you know absorbed the acid from the acid
rain what are ways in which we can help
again if this is a fossil fuel problem
well one of the obvious ways is let's
cut back on our use of fossil fuels
exploring alternatives like wind energy
and solar energy and again trying to use
fuel efficient automobiles whenever we
have the means to exploring public
transportation riding bicycles these are
easy things that the average person can
do to help reduce the effects of acid
rain when we look at you know technology
so technology on automobiles I think it
was in the 1970s when catalytic
converters became law here in the United
States cars have to have a catalytic
converter because they are wonderful and
neutralizing some of the harmful
pollutant that come out of the exhaust
of automobiles another way to help and
now this is only a temporary solution
but is to add what's called a buffer
into waterways and on the land that
might be affected by acid rain in the
picture here you see a process called
liming what this is is crushed limestone
limestone as a rock and limestone
actually will counteract some of the
effects that the acid will have so by
crushing limestone and like a powder and
spreading the powder over the land and
dumping a bunch of the limestone powder
into waterways it's a way to neutralize
some of the effects of the acid of
course this is only a temporary solution
but it's a way to just buy some time
until we can figure out more permanent
ways to help
so the next one to mention is called
biomagnification now sometimes you'll
hear this called bio accumulation as
well and this is where the concentration
of the toxin or pollutants just
increases as you go higher and higher
and higher up the food chain so the
cause of this are just a variety of
pollutants that can enter an ecosystem
whether it's air pollution or water
pollution so in my animation here we see
the green circles represent green algae
that are in let's say a lake and so the
pollution from the from the environment
maybe there's some agriculture nearby
point is there's some pollution that's
entered the waterway here and it's
diffusing into the cells of the green
algae so as time goes by the
concentration of the pollutant in the
algae increases well this is gonna move
up the food chain because small fish
will come along and eat the green algae
and when they do the pollution from the
algae builds up into the tissue of the
small fish and so we see that the
pollutants accumulate in the food chain
and the as we go higher and higher up
the trophic level and so when we move
higher on the trophic levels we're gonna
see well a larger fish may come and eat
these two smaller fish and by doing so
the larger fish is getting a real strong
dose of these pollutants and it builds
up in the tissue of the larger fish and
let's say eventually a human goes
fishing one day and they throw their
fishing line into the lake or the ocean
of the pond of the stream and they catch
this fish they take it home they fry it
up and they consume it as part of their
meal well now the pollution is as has
accumulated in higher levels of the food
chain to the point where the human can
get sick an example of biomagnification
you might be familiar with is in mercury
when we examine this picture we see the
mercury kind of enters waterways from
let's say mining facilities and it
builds up first in small organisms
krill and then salmon and Pollock and
oyster eat the krill and then trout and
tuna will eat those the salmon the
Pollock and the oyster and then shark
and pike and albacore and halibut will
eat the trout and the tuna and so when
you look at the red meters at the bottom
it's recommended not to consume
organisms like albacore and halibut on a
regular basis it says they eat only a
few times per month just to be safe that
you're not consuming large amounts of
mercury so ways in which we can help
with biomagnification well we can try to
support you know products at the grocery
store that are marked USDA Organic
organically grown foods means that they
were grown without the use of artificial
fertilizers and pesticides of course try
to recycle wherever we can try to
prevent some of these toxins from
entering the environment in the first
place and you know not dumping materials
you know down storm drains and such
because you know in storm drains if we
dump you know used motor oil or
something down a storm drain it might
eventually lead directly into a river or
a stream or an ocean which could of
course pollute that particular
environment
so let's move to the next topic deep
depletion of the ozone layer
what is the ozone layer here we have in
my animation it's a layer of our
atmosphere that blocks UV radiation from
the Sun you can see that the symbol Oh
three three oxygen masks use me three
oxygen atoms stuck together make up the
molecule called ozone ER does a
wonderful job preventing UV radiation
from the Sun from striking the surface
of the earth well what's the problem
then the problem is that a man-made
chemical abbreviated CFCs
chlorofluorocarbons chlorine fluorine
and carbon bonded together
chlorofluorocarbons and these tend to
come from aerosols from the coolant of
refrigerators from the coolant in air
conditioners and from the production of
foam products well by releasing these
CFCs into the air what they cause is the
destruction of oh three of ozone
molecules they thin out the ozone layer
and by doing this this allows more UV
radiation from the Sun to strike the
surface because you can see the ozone
layer is not as thick that's not
absorbing and blocking as much UV
radiation as it normally should well in
this picture here we have a picture
looking down at Antarctica and the blue
area represents a real thin layer of the
ozone layer and in 1984 this whole was
discovered now it's not a complete whole
it's just a thinned out area of the
ozone where zone layer where a lot of
radiation from the Sun is striking now
the good news is there's no real-life
not much life on Antarctica but some
years this whole expands some years it
contracts and of course we don't want it
to get worse
well what are some of the effects of
extra amounts of UV radiation reaching
the surface well we look at this picture
right here look on the Left where it
says before there's an incoming photon
of UV radiation striking a molecule of
DNA now look on the right the molecule
of DNA has been broken open because UV
radiation is a known mutagen causes DNA
mutations by breaking apart as from T's
and C's from G's well this has some
consequences for example skin cancers
are on the rise in areas that receive
more UV radiation here we have a patch
of skin showing an example of melanoma
which is a type of skin cancer and so
how can we help well what we can do is
we can of course try to reduce our use
of CFCs we'll talk about that more in a
moment but also regrow trees because
trees make oxygen oxygen eventually
turns into ozone high up in the
atmosphere so trees by making oxygen can
actually help to replenish the ozone
layer now I want to end with the ozone
layer talking about something positive
this graph is actually a very positive
looking graph notice how the Lions are
going downward what this is showing is
the amount the the use of CFCs around
the world is dropping and this is really
good news because CFCs damage the ozone
layer well the reason CFCs are dropping
is because in 1987 an international
agreement called the Montreal Protocol
banned the use of chlorofluorocarbons
and as a result we're starting to see
the ozone layer replenish itself so this
problem right here the depletion of the
ozone layer should be looked at as a
positive as a ray of light as a beam of
light ironically speaking in that we can
we as society can solve tough problems
okay moving on to the next topic smog
also known as ground-level ozone here we
have a picture of Los Angeles and you
can see that gray film over the skyline
of downtown Los Angeles you know that's
not normal that shouldn't be there that
smog well what is smog it's a fog or a
haze combined with smoke and other
atmospheric pollutants here's a picture
of New York City you know here's a
picture of Beijing China on the left is
a picture after its rained for a few
days you know the rain kind of washed
all the smog out of the sky but the
picture on the right kind of shows kind
of an average day in this area so what's
the problem what's causing smog well
again it's from the burning of fossil
fuels from industry and power plants to
automobiles around the world the there
are consequences of burning fossil fuels
so in general let's talk about how smog
forms in the sky there is oxygen you
know oxygen that we breathe and one of
the pollutants in general that creates
smog is a pollutant called NOx NO x
nitrogen oxides so they come out of cars
comes from the burning of fossil fuels
and the oxygen in the sky and the
nitrogen oxides will react with the
sunlight this is one of the reasons why
Los Angeles is so smoggy because again
we have lots of cars and lots of
sunlight but it will react with the
sunlight and when it does it causes a
chemical reaction that creates smog also
called ground-level ozone ozone near the
ground oh three near the ground and
ozone is a poisonous molecule now we
just got done talking about the ozone
layer now don't confuse the two
ozone is a poisonous gas but when it's
you know miles and miles and miles above
the ground in the atmosphere blocking UV
radiation that's wonderful people don't
live in that layer of the atmosphere but
when ozone is near the ground we have to
live amongst that we have to breathe it
it gets you know in our eyes and causes
burning and causes all kinds of problems
for people with respiratory ailments and
so here are some of the effects of why
smog is harmful you can see in the
picture burning eyes throats irritates
the mucous membranes shortness of breath
wheezing and coughing people who are
more prone to asthma suffer more asthma
attacks chest pains when they're
inhaling pulmonary inflammation
increased increased risk of heart
attacks and so these are some of the
effects of living in areas that are
highly to have high levels of smog or
ground-level ozone well it's not just
humans that are affected when we look at
this picture the plant on the left was
grown in smog in a smoggy environment
the plant on the right was grown in you
know normal conditions you can see smog
and ground-level ozone even affects
crops and plants and their ability to
grow well what are ways to help well
again if this is caused by the burning
of fossil fuels trying to explore
alternatives again wind and solar power
and on your you know personal life may
be trying to use your bicycle more often
and exploring public transportation and
when possible trying to find more
fuel-efficient forms of transportation
and again comes down that you know
planting trees when I found this picture
I just kind of giggled because again of
a photo op with former president and
first lady President Nixon and mrs.
Nixon in this picture from probably
sometime in the 1970s I just thought it
was a fun picture to include in this but
planting trees helps to remove again a
lot of air pollutants
so the next step I want to mention is
called deforestation and this is a
pretty straightforward topic it's the
clearing of forested areas you know this
picture here shows what's called what's
left over from slash-and-burn
agriculture and so people will slash
down the trees and burn the area why do
they do this well the layer of ash
provides newly this newly cleared land
with a nutrient-rich layer to fertilize
crops eventually they're gonna turn this
land into farmland the problem is this
land is only fertile for a couple of
years before the nutrients are used up
and then the farmers move on to another
area of the forest slash and burn that
area and stay there for a few years and
then move on and the process just
repeats itself and so we see again the
devastation it comes from you know
deforestation in this picture looking
down from high high high above you can
see the cleared effects of deforestation
and in this picture on the left 1975
Bolivia on the right 2003 you can see
the the difference that a couple of
decades have made I wish I had a a more
up-to-date picture than 2003 but still
even in this picture here you can kind
of see how dramatic the area has changed
and so what is the reasons for
deforestation well around the world
there's a high demand for wood products
for building materials wood for burning
for fuel and for construction and for
furniture so there's a big demand and
let's not forget paper products there's
a big demand for wood products around
the world not only that but a lot of
areas that are deforested like you see
here are termed and turned into farmland
in order to grow various crops to you
know feed humanity
you know and so what are some problems
have some consequences as a result of
deforestation well you know some of the
obvious would be lack of biodiversity
and species extinction when you look at
this food chain if the trees and plants
are maybe not completely removed but
very greatly hindered that's gonna have
a trickle up effect as you move up and
up and up the food chain you know when
we look at this formula here this is the
formula of photosynthesis we see that
carbon dioxide is one of the reactants
on the left of the arrow one of the
ingredients needed for photosynthesis to
occur and with less plants and trees on
this earth because of deforestation
there's just less carbon dioxide being
removed from the sky when I look at this
graph right here there's two things to
look first look at the the the blue line
the blue line shows the amount of carbon
dioxide over the past maybe 200 years or
so going up and up and up and up and up
and there's a variety of reasons for
that number one were burning more fossil
fuels but number two is by removing
forests as we are we are removing the
things that will suck up carbon dioxide
and then you look at the red lines the
red line shows the average global
temperature and as the blue line goes up
notice the pattern that the red line
goes up as well you know one year it's a
little warm one year it's a little
cooler next year it's a little warm next
year it's a little cooler but overall
the red line is trending upward as the
blue line trends upward and so another
consequence of deforestation is a is a
problem called desertification this is
where wind and rain will carry soil away
here we have a nice um wind blowing but
trees you know are a great windbreaker
they block wind and they hold topsoil
down and so trees are great natural
barriers they prevent erosion but when
the areas are deforested let's remove
the trees or the wind and not just win
but also rain wind will carry away the
topsoil blows it away and what what's
left behind
is this very dry unusable land where you
really can't grow crops and this process
is called desertification because the
land resembles the desert desert soil
when we look at this picture right here
you can see a wonderful example of
desertification you know this area above
is in Haiti you know Haiti is not a
desert area Haiti is a tropical area but
when we look at this area here this
deforested area it looks like you're
looking at desert land from above and so
ways to help deforestation well the
obvious is to reforest reforestation you
know in this picture right here I
thought this was a wonderful example
reforestation in between Lake Tahoe and
Reno Nevada
the replanting of forests on a massive
scale it's gonna take you know a lot of
it this action around the world to kind
of counter some of the effects of
deforestation and of course to recycle
wherever possible you know it's not just
recycling paper what you see right here
but also you know wood products you know
people don't like to buy used furniture
that's why if you look for rustic
furniture it's just the fancy we have
seen used and reconditioned so you know
check sources like Craigslist here in
the US that's a great way to find used
or excuse me rustic furniture as a way
to kind of give second life to wood
products and used furniture rustic
furniture excuse me now this way to help
right here may not apply to most people
but for those that it does apply to you
know try to find sustainable ways in
which farming can be improved upon cover
crops in this picture are planted during
the offseason when soil might left be
left bare and these crops will protect
and build the soil health by preventing
erosion and replenish nutrients but you
know from a consumer point of view you
know what can the consumer do who's not
the farmer you know by exploring foods
that are organically grown you know
that's a pretty good sign if you buy if
you're supporting organically
foods and purchasing them at grocery
stores you know that's a pretty good
step in the right direction
okay so the final topic I want to
mention in this video is what are called
invasive species you know these are
foreign organisms that are introduced
into a new habitat and they kind of
upset the balance of that new habitat
the picture here shows adorably cute
European rabbits and they were
introduced to Australia for hunting
purposes and every year they caused
millions and millions of dollars in loss
of crops because they've become so
overpopulated in Australia that they eat
the crops and causes economic loss so
they have over they have overpopulated
so much they've thrown off the natural
balance in their ecosystem and so what's
causing invasive species while there's a
variety of reasons you know the pet
industry for example this picture shows
a Burmese python which are native to
Burma and Southeast Asia and they have
been released into the Florida
Everglades where they have multiplied
and have really become such a nuisance
that they you know are destroying and
hunting and killing a lot of the native
organisms but the pet industry was is
responsible for this one here what do I
mean by free-ride organisms well here's
area a and there's a boat and in the
loading of cargo onto a boat let's say
these mice are these rats get onto the
boat and then the ship eventually sets
sail to area B and in the unloading of
the cargo the the mice or the rats get
off the boat and are now transported to
this new area this is what I mean by
free ride organisms and a great example
of free ride organisms are in the Great
Lakes the zebra mussels zebra mussels
are native to Europe and they arrived
into the United States from shipping
vessels and they've overtaken the Great
Lakes and they clog water pipes and they
disrupt the food webs and we'll talk
more about these in a little bit another
interesting example I think is the small
Asian Mongoose which was introduced
to Hawaii to combat rats the problem
that people didn't realize is that the
Asian Mongoose is diurnal which means
it's active during the day and rats are
nocturnal which means they're active
during the night so the Mongoose never
really encountered the rats because
they're active during different times of
the day and ultimately in order to
survive the Mongoose has been eating
native birds and turtle eggs and has
really thrown the ecosystem out of
balance in Hawaii and so what are some
effects of invasive species well the big
one is it it throws off the balance of
food webs I brought up you know the the
zebra mussels we wouldn't when we look
at this food web here here's the zebra
mussels over here on the left in the red
flashing circle and we can see that
zebra mussels will filter and eat
plankton but by doing so they are
reducing the amount of available
plankton for the native organisms and it
really throws stress into the
survivability of the other organisms low
on the food chain that would normally be
eating the plankton and not only that so
in this case the zebra mussels because
they just filter feed they just suck
water into them and trap a lot of
plankton they don't really go out and
hunt so they really out-compete the
native species that live in this
particular area and not only that but
they cause tremendous economic loss in
this picture here we see a oh I forgot
what this was an intake valve or
something but a man-made structure
covered completely covered in zebra
mussels and the only way to you know
remove the zebra mussels is to you know
scrape them off and blast them with hot
water to try to you know maybe make
repairs on this pipe here that you see
in the picture
and so what are ways to help prevent
invasive species well the big thing is
to you know follow the laws that are in
place that restrict bringing foreign
species in and out when I look at this
picture here I can see the sign at the
bottom it says never release aquarium
plants water or animals because again by
doing so you might be introducing
foreign species into a new habitat in
this picture right here the sign says to
stop the spread of zebra mussels by
cleaning your boat zebra mussels will
attach themselves to the outer hull of a
boat and so after let's say a weekend of
boating scraping off the zebra mussels
before you go boating in another
location is a good way to stop the
spread of invasive species and in some
cases of course I'm not implying that
people take controlled burns into their
own hands but what you're seeing in this
picture is a controlled burn done by the
Forest Service management system so
again I'm not implying that people go
and set small fires to control invasive
plants but this is done by you know land
management bureaus
okay so there we have you know some of
the consequences of overpopulation so if
you're in my biology class pause the
video and try to answer these questions
and I'm happy to check your answers
before school or after school one day
thanks for watching